let me see those bumps ladies I'm gonna
get it up tech reviews definitely bigger
how are you feeling right now you are in
the homestretch sisters now third
trimester here and I can't like I am
just totally in all the fact that like
clearly the two of you of your twins but
you're two weeks apart we can have a
week and a half
very similar and so we kind of feel like
these babies are gonna come on the same
day you guys have things packed are you
ready and raring to go so we do we
started having things packed I think
Brian's a little bit more prepared than
we did our first test ride to the
hospital yesterday and we got lost and I
guess that's why you do these things but
I was like didn't you have it in the GPS
he's like no I thought it was just this
way and I was like oh my gosh what have
this cravings been you know I learned I
think this sounds so silly but I think
because we are in a hundred and ten
degree heat I protein shakes like I want
I know that's it
I love protein shakes Bree and I go we
do though crepe good time cards I think
because for so long green I were so
careful with our carbon tape being
professor's press lean on HDTV that I
told breathe every day I have to have
some type of park and Artem is just an
incredible Baker so I'm having like a
lot of sourdough bread oh good okay so
any updates on your birthday plans so
for me and totally still want to film
the experience in that's the plan as and
now things are changing it's like week
we do to cope in nineteen as of now only
arm can be in there so Artem would have
to film but we're praying that by the
time I delivered that because I really
want brie in there with me and I'm
hoping that we could bring a total
Bella's producers so brie Inara can just
be in the moment with me and not worry
about filming so it's just we have to
follow state estate rules and all due to
coven 19 so in a perfect world for me I
would have our total Bellas producer in
there filming and have my sister and
Artem by my side and just introduce her
baby to the world you know I'm like
Nikki I you know I don't experience with
birdie and even though it was different
than what I thought
it's still really fun to go back and see
it so I want to film this experience
because I want to see if it's gonna be
the same or different as right now my
pictures are crossed that section so but
I told the cameras of Nikki you had
mentioned that you had a scare with a
baby recently is everything okay being
good as it was there was just something
they saw and our baby's heart and so
they just they had to take a double look
they just saw a speck and they were like
this you know might not be great and in
the end thing thought it wasn't anything
not normal it was something that a lot
of babies go through our baby is so
extremely healthy I think God so much
for that but it was scary because you
had to wait so many days for testing and
all that and they just it felt like
years and I just wanted to know but in
the end thank goodness everything was
all okay how was Miss birdy doing great
does she have a preference as to you
know does she want a little brother or a
little sister I think she wants a little
sister you saying that I feel like all
the girls like there's one up song who's
like that
yeah to dress up and probably boss
around
but she's are doing really good you know
I think it's gonna be hard on her but
the babies come because of the last
couple months she's had both Brian
Knight and Nicole Arden's attention and
it's all about her and then Tom less
than eight weeks it won't be so I'm
nervous for that but she you know the
one thing I'm really every day I kind of
teacher is how much I need help and I
need you to help mama and like I with
laundry and we'll do the dishes and all
these things and I've been sure her rock
the baby so I think she's gonna really
love being an older sister yeah like he
seems very nurturing yeah yeah I can't
wait to know what the gender of the baby
is about at all but I think it's so
mind-blowing to me the Nikki you know
with the gender of this baby is you've
known for a long time and girlfriend you
have kept quite the secret I have so tip
that's why I'm excited that everyone's
friendly gonna note because then now I
can like share pictures of the nursery
and like not have to always think about
like what like say babies say baby don't
say whatever it's been really tough I'm
surprised that I've been so open about
it
so good where are you guys on names and
what if there's a chance that you both
want the same name we're so weird but I
have a Russian so my names are very
different because I have to follow
traditions three day there yeah and we
also have to stick to the beads because
Brian is whole family will be so every
one of our family's beads so that makes
it a little tough but if we have a boy
we really want to name him after Brian's
dad and then we have a girl really torn
between like five names it's actually
crazy because Brian might have there's
kind of one more book like okay we
really like but he keeps throwing these
names out real quick free I know yeah
now Nicky you said that you have
obviously your baby will be part
brushing and you have to go by Russian
tradition so what is that enlighten us
as far as like middle names do no matter
what like Russian tradition girl or boy
you always take the father's middle name
and also arms last seems obviously very
Russian so thinking of names to flow it
very difficult like very cool so we
finally y'all are just the two of you
juggle so much at once and here you are
juggling motherhood together as well you
recently put out a New York Times
best-selling memoir also had you going
into some really dark times that you had
to relive yeah how was that process for
you really hard it's crazy because it
took us two half years to write the book
and it kind of like we were going in
therapy again like you know when you're
you have to read those stories are we
talking about it it's it's crazy how all
the feelings
and feelings that you once that you can
control and then you know really grew
away from they're all back there but
Nicole I knew it was really important to
tell this story yeah a lot of stories
that we've never talked about on total
divas total Bella's or ever really and
are there to be careers so we're like
you know what it's time now that people
know about like our child in childhood
and what made us strong women and the
things we learned that or hope other
people can learn from too because Nicole
and I do believe it when you go through
something bad you could victimize
yourself really easy and it's hard to
grow some that or you could leave
yourself as a survivor and become really
strong from something and that's really
the mess if you want to hit everyone
you've both been very open about your
relationships and one in particular
Nikki that you talked about with your
book was of course your very public
relationship with John whom you do not
name in the book because you want to
keep it focused on you John reached out
to you since the release of your book to
give you any sort of feedback or
response yeah what was actually he said
Green I had the sweetest text of just
congratulating us on our book on New
York Times bestseller that's one thing
that John is just so has always been so
beautiful that he's such AI always was
like you need to be a motivational
speaker like he has such a beautiful
words you see it on his Twitter he's
very motivating and when he sent a hurry
and I was just the words were so
beautiful it made us feel very proud of
like what we did and feel very
accomplished so yeah thats we heard from
that from the book and he just he was
proud of the fact that we told our story
and and i feel like right now we are
going through so much turmoil in this
world there's so much pain and hatred
out there and here you are two beautiful
women that are preparing on being
mothers and what is it that you are
hoping for your children at this time
what lessons are you hoping to and still
within them and conversations that you
hope to have with them you know for
myself just even haven't 300 and then a
baby come in and they've written this to
one of my like social media platform
but we have to educate our kids we have
to educate our youth of the things that
are going on we don't want to shelter
them because we'll never learn an Amber
DS first teacher first role model I'm
the first person the teacher I thought
loved to teach her all these different
things so it's my duty as a parent to
instill in her love and kindness and
peace and I think 2020 is gonna be one
of those years that we're gonna tell our
kids it was a hard year to live but it
brought so much change and change we
needed I feel like at the end of 2020
we're all gonna be like you know what we
needed this we all needed to be in our
houses
think about our lives we needed to stand
up and think to ourselves like do you
know what black lives matter do you
educate yourself like to see community
that needs everyone's help I think this
year we're all gonna toast when 2021
comes and be like we all needed this and
now we all feel good I see a big shift
and everything but I feel like I'm
starting to see the good come behind and
so I won't both my kids tonight and I'm
gonna tell when we were three living it
the other one your mommy's belly but at
the same time you know we were all part
of that change that needed
[Music]